je vais le faire aujourd'hui
J'ai hâte de retravailler avec vous aujourd'hui dans ma famille
Je suis le seul qui peut travailler, j'ai besoin d'argent
pourquoi est-ce arrivé
être terminé
[musique]
je n'ai pas le choix
Est-ce la première fois que vous venez dans le donjon de la Terre?
je te protègerai
[musique]
allons-nous aussi commencer
attaquecommencer
Tant que vous continuez à vous battre comme d'habitude, tout ira bien
Suis-je la personne sympathique qui apprend en surveillant ses arrières
Je ne pense pas que cela convienne à un leader
tu as eu un réveil post-scolaire
pas
Comment vivre le rôle d'un chasseur
un seul à survivre
Merci de rester timide
Combien de temps vas-tu me pousser là-dedans
Au fait, es-tu prêt à mourir ?
Je peux vraiment devenir plus fort